you're gonna be one of those hilarious
box within a box it's not hilarious I'll
tell you that though
[Music]
hey what's up guys this is Chris D'Elia
and we're gonna be tricking some people
in the spirit of Christmas we are taking
two buzz feeders and they think that
they're here for the perfect Christmas
gift based on their personality but what
they don't know is that the only thing
inside of these oversized boxes are just
more boxes that's what they're getting
for Christmas which I guess comes down
to nothing will show your personality is
like I said I was fun
nice and I like fried chicken and so
maybe it's fried chicken related I'm
like a mix of Rihanna and Malcolm X Wow
maybe it's like a fried chicken magnet
or something actually yeah you're right
about that but I'm also very sensitive
yeah I want to consider that's it's
moving it's moving in there don't play
me it has to move to get to you this is
just for me yeah this is for you just
what you do whatever you're getting yeah
that's very weird
[Music]
it means something when you gets when
you get to the gift that you understand
why that's real fast another box this is
actually the best paper though perhaps
that it's a metaphor
the greatest gift of all I mean that's
cool but then also it'd be way better if
it was like a Playstation I mean there's
just like not a gift
I heard of me out no I can still hold
Fried Chicken by the way I would like
what do you think's in there no no but
I'm bleeding a little bit
[Music]
no no nothing
well maybe the greatest gift of all is
you know I mean this wasn't my idea it's
fine you can keep this as a reminder
yeah or what we have for you
what there's a very special Starbucks
and gift card man actually the best joke
is this well I just left Starbucks and
turns out that card actually was empty
oh man Merry Christmas that's pretty
funny it's pretty funny except I do you
have to buy my own copy now